when you first heard about Cindy's
passing what was the first thing that
went through your mind I almost had like
two images simultaneously one was the
first time I met her when when she did
Happy Days with Penny Marshall this is
La Verne de Fazio She's Mine
and this is Shirley Feeney she's yours
as you can see
nice to meet you Richie my pleasure then
I I also had the great privilege of
doing a play with Cindy not that long
ago so just a few years ago we did a
play together played husband and wife
play called Middletown and I instantly
went right to that because because we
were working so closely together on that
play and
and it really hit me it really I I I I
was
in it just bubbled up and I started
crying and I was like
I think you know because it encompassed
that part of going back to Happy Days
and encompassed so much and and she was
so wonderful she was such a wonderful
lady and terrific actress of course what
was it like working together doing the
play together and how did that help you
get to know Cindy even better
it was a total Joy I mean
everything about working with her I mean
she's one of the kindest most gracious
sweetest people you'll ever meet and and
and then as an actress so she I mean she
she's done such great work in comedy and
drama and the play that we were doing
was that it was it was both comedy and
drama
and playing husband and wife I mean it
was it just flowed it was just so
there was there was no nothing that was
a strain or or you had to work at it
just seemed to just come like like from
above or something it was just great
when was the last time you had a chance
to speak to Cindy
the last time we she and Anson Williams
have played Patsy and myself we
surprised Ron Howard at an event that
was about nine months ago uh he he and
his brother were doing a speaking
engagement about their book that they
had written together called the boys and
um he didn't know we were going to be
there so so we were there to surprise
him and and Cindy was there it was the
last time I got to speak with her Ah
that's so sad really sad
what do you remember about that
about that today yeah
um just how well she was so alive and
then as she always was and vibrant and
and and we were talking about we were
talking about doing something together
there was a a show that maybe she Anson
and I were going to do together and we
were excited about the prospects of it
but then it kind of got pushed off so I
forgot about it and then it came up
again recently and I was thinking about
it you know just about a month ago so
those are things that really came to the
front of my my brain immediately you
know because we would have been working
together again
uh but you know then I think back at
some of the great work she did you know
the movie the conversation with
Coppola's film very dramatic film and
and
um but then the comedy as well of course
in Laverne Shirley he's still blaming me
for that how can he blame you for a
fight I kind of started it
well you were actually in the first
scene when the world got to meet Cindy
on Happy Days yes what do you remember
about that well I just remember
um how great they were together I mean
this was the first time they'd worked
together and and they came in and it was
just like this this energy level just
went up to the roof when the two of them
started doing their scene and and then
they had some I had some interaction
with them more with Penny than Cindy but
I just remember sitting there being and
my part in that episode was watching and
like getting a big kick out of seeing
these two characters and I didn't have
to act I mean it was just it was it was
amazing to watch the two of them so and
then it was you know then we found out
pretty shortly after oh they got their
own show now we will have this lasting
Archive of Cindy through her great work
on Laverne and Shirley and other things
yes what do you think her Legacy will be
well definitely Laverne and Shirley's
going to be right up there for me
graffiti was such a such a landmark film
really a landmark film and she was great
in it as as Ron Howard's girlfriend
um those two Phil I mean those two
projects
um and I think the conversation
um is going to linger on I mean that's
not going to go away that film and and
people will be surprised who don't know
that side of her when they see the
conversation they go wow look at the
range that she had look at the dramatic
chops that she had and they only think
of her you know as sure if they only
know her Shirley Feeney they'll be very
surprised you mentioned her range but
also talking to Henry he has said that
there was a time where he was angry
about The Fawns right he didn't like the
funds and maybe there was a point where
you were angry about your character is
there ever a time where you all you know
even Cindy were like I just want to
leave this thing behind me but then you
came back to it later there definitely
was that time when you feel like it's a
monkey on your on your back because
because of the fact that there was only
the three networks and you had so many
people watching the phenomenon of of
getting Typecast was much more prevalent
than I think now because of because of
you know there's so many different
programs on for people to see so
you knew when I started seeing when I
wanted to go out for other roles and he
started seeing well they won't even let
me audition because they oh no they
don't think you're the right type
because they think of you as as rough
yeah and I'm going that's not who I am
in real life I wasn't really like that
character it didn't matter you know so
you couldn't when you I started seeing
the handwriting where I couldn't even
get to audition for some of these roles
then it was like you wanted to create
separation from that character in any
way you could because you wanted to to
survive as an actor
so it's self-preservation to try to
separate yourself so I understand it's
why I mean Henry went through it we all
went through that
do you have a favorite Cindy moment
a favorite moment you filmed with her
favorite episode you did with her
anything like that because I didn't do
too many I didn't do any of the episodes
of their show
um the Crossovers
so so my favorite moments would be on
stage with her during that play
Middletown because because you know we
were on stage every night for you know
90 minutes and we did the play in a
couple of different cities
um and so so those are my memories that
I'll remember most
foreign